nous vivons une époque formidable
l'ancien système s'effondre les régimes
politiques actuelles périclite la
morosité et absolue
la faillite est réel tout est bloqué ça
gronde nous dit on c'est la crise et ça
dure depuis des années
alors là je veux la tête au premier rang
genre elle va nous faire le coup de la
crise qui se transforme en opportunité
alors pas du tout je vais vous raconter
pourquoi je suis dans cet état je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez d'un jour où
la france avec une tragédie la france a
perdu 1 à pas dans son nom ni dans sa
chair dans le système de notation
internationales qui évalue la
performance financière des états
tragique
ce jour là forcément j'écoute de loin
jusqu'à 1 jeudi
mon jeudi noir à moi quatre rendez vous
avec des présidents de groupe
quatre projets annulés une raison
commune invoqué la perte de ce fameux a
alors là j'écoute
forcément ça me touche autour de moi des
entrepreneurs continuent de développer
leurs projets des artistes continuent de
créer des producteurs continuent de
produire au fur et à mesure des
expositions
quelle est donc cette tragédie dont les
médias s'emparent que les politiques
relais massivement nous collant une
espèce d'angoissé générale à l'équipe à
lagence ferment avec l'équipe nous
décidons alors d'envoyer un mail l'objet
du mail aa nous allons noté avec audace
optimisme force détermination notre état
et nous écrivons gens proches de nous
clients partenaires créateur
prestataires ceux qui continuent de
développer leurs projets avec des seins
ou pas merci nous envoyer vos
témoignages
et là ça nous tombe dessus des mots des
poèmes des photos des vidéos des croquis
des illustrations il ya même des
articles des artistes qui semaine
qu'ils se mettent pardon a créé pour
l'occasion au mieux tout ça une oeuvre
me touche particulièrement
c'est une vidéo sur la voix de tous les
journalistes du monde qui raconte
toujours sur le même ton les
catastrophes les plus inhumaines les
autres les unes que les autres sur
toutes ces voix un artiste marc furlan
vient poser la sienne en surimpression
dans toutes les langues du monde il nous
dit i'm not afraid nottingham y aideront
je n'ai pas peur je n'ai pas peur je
n'ai pas peur comme un mantra ça dure
deux minutes
le mantra dans certaines religions comme
l'hindouisme le bouddhisme c'est un
chant qui est fondée sur la répétition
des sont presque mécanique
le mantra ça un but canaliser le mental
discursif cette tête qui résonne et qui
nous empêche de nous connecter à nos
émotions
le mantra ça permet ça presque
mécaniquement
alors pourquoi ça résonne en moi à ce
moment là aussi fortement
je me souviens de deux trois trucs très
jeune je travaillais dans un grand
groupe de communication où on m'a confié
des responsabilités avec pas mal d'enjeu
ce jour-là une personne s'approche de
moi et me dit tu sais c'est ce qui
montre le plus haut le plus vite qu'ils
tombent aussi le plus vite tout en bas
bon courage
hyper encourageant ce jour là et tous
les jours j'ai exercé ce job je me suis
répété je ne tomberai pas je ne tomberai
pas je ne tomberai pas pourquoi ça
résonne en moi et c'est certainement
beaucoup plus lointain est beaucoup plus
inconscient je suis né avec les hanches
à l'envers impossible de marcher
ceux qui chantaient autour de moi mes
parents
les médecins elle marchera mois en du
forte nouvelles techniques médicales un
plâtre du bout des orteils jusqu'en haut
du ventre les jambes tenue en extension
par une barre de fer pendant des mois
mais en ce sens retourner elle marchera
17 ans
voilà pourquoi ça résonne forcément
aussi fort autour de moi et pourtant ce
jour là je note quelque chose la vidéo
s'appelle le point zéro du monde
pas de chance les incantations ne
suffisent pas qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
après comment comment construire
différemment
et si ce point zéro c'était un point de
départ je me suis arrêté
je me suis posée j'ai réfléchi forcément
à toutes ces années où je me
construisait beaucoup sur ce je n'ai pas
peur je ne tomberai pas jeûner jouerait
pas qui signifiait que j'étais beaucoup
dans la négation je me construisait
contre contre l'échec contre l'ennui
contre la fatalité contre les autres
donc forcément pas besoin de vous dire
que j'étais pas très heureuse et que je
pouvais me sentir assez seul le point
zéro du monde un point de départ où un
premier pas ça fait quelques années
maintenant que je crée des plateformes
en france et ailleurs mais j'ai commencé
en france pour assembler les cultures
les talents les gens pour générer des
projets positifs différent il ya trois
pas à faire pour recréer positivement le
premier
la première chose que j'ai apprise c'est
la force du collectif
nous sommes nombreux
j'ai mis en j'ai rencontré pas mal de
gens quand j'ai décidé de faire cette
première plateforme leur aaa chez emi en
tout petit ce soir parce que j'en oublie
plainte comme ça il le remarque ont pas
mais je suis sûr qu autour de vous vous
en connaissez beaucoup et puis vous
connaissez sûrement d'autres communautés
créatives d'autres plateformes
vous connaissez certainement les
conspirateurs positif matthieu gaudin
make sense ashoka de family la clinton
global initiative nous sommes nombreux
j'ai surtout rencontré quand j'ai décidé
de faire tout ça des gens qui font des
gens qui osent des gens qui se
mobilisent alors nous aussi avec le aaa
nous avons décidé d'en faire un
catalyseur de projets
audacieux un sens et parfois démesurées
nous avons développé il ya le temps
ensemble
une exposition un parcours anti crise la
première le premier temps du parcours
poser une question mais quel est donc ce
monde que l'on voudrait quitter des
artistes des architectes des designers
s'exprime sur ce premier temps ils nous
répondent ça ce système asfeld et on
veut quitter le gâchis alimentaire le
temps court
l'urgence le monde de la finance la
surconsommation en espèces de couloir un
peu noir comment on fait pour passer un
monde différent
le deuxième temps du parcours c'était la
boîte à outils de coire at on besoin
pour passer vers ce monde d'après là
encore on nous répond de solidarité
d'amour de poésie d'humour de force de
nature de militantisme quand même un peu
de poésie
le troisième temps du parcours posé la
question mais qu'elle sait donc ce monde
d'après alors là je vous rassure
personne ne sait certains tout le monde
travaille ensemble et certains imaginent
on se retrouve avec des trucs comme ça
fabrice hyber qui imaginent une piste
d'atterrissage pour les habitants du
futur ces extraterrestres que forcément
personne ne connaît blanca li une
danseuse fait une vidéo où le monde
entier le monde d'après serait devenue
une dune de sable chaud géante dans
lequel on aurait envie de se rouler à
l'infini pour l'épouser arthur simoni
alors lui il est venu avec un arbre et
il a vendu des étiquettes des bons pour
bon pour le monde d'après bon pour la
vie jean françois piège et nous a révélé
la recette de la bouche et du bonheur
elles existent je vous la recommande
voilà trois semaines 60 créateurs une
équipe de pros de merveilleuses quand
même il faut le dire trente mille
visiteurs en dix jours la force du
collectif
c'est le premier pas que j'ai appris
c'est pour recréer différemment il faut
se nourrir de la force des autres
pas comme un glouton pas comme quelqu'un
qui digère tout pour lui mais comme un
passeur comme quelqu'un qui sort de son
cadre justement pour aller dans le cadre
des autres on y voit souvent des choses
incroyables
la deuxième chose que j'ai appris c'est
que vous recréez il faut donner la force
à ceux qui créent à ceux qui innovent à
ceux qui se mobilisent
ça fait plusieurs années maintenant je
travaille dans le monde arabe
et j'ai appris là bas deux très jolis
mots le premier c'est celui là que je me
garderai bien de prononcer mais qui
signifie que le mot ingénieurs
exactement le même que celui qui désigne
les inventeurs reconnaît leur capacité à
inventer à transformer le monde
pourquoi je retiens ça c'est qu'il ya
une étude ya peu de temps qu'il ya
recensé qu'en france les gens capables
de changer le monde qui était proche des
métiers de la création 25%
si on prend cette même étude et qu'on
additionne en disant mais ajoutons les
scientifiques les chercheurs les codeurs
ces chercheurs de solutions 52% majorité
le deuxième mot que j'ai appris c'est
celui là
là aussi je vais pas le prononcer très
très bien mais ça se dit la zakat la
zakat c'est un des piliers de l'islam
si je le traduis en français ça donne un
truc comme l'aumône où la charité manque
un truc la zakat ça veut dire qu'on
grand le succès de la vie nous a donné
et qu'on permet à l'autre de créer
quelque chose de différent
c'est un peu le give back anglais
pourquoi ça me touche c'est qu'à un
moment
noam de construction c'est aussi vouloir
remettre plus de justice plus d'
équilibre vous l'appellerait comme vous
voudrez et ça marche
regardez les gros le gouvernement et la
french tech qui laisse la place à ceux
qui sont dans l'innovation sociale les
départements d'innovation des très
grands groupes
les incubateurs ce qui rentre dans les
structures des grandes entreprises
c'est un politique ces hommes d'affaires
qui viennent nous voir nous les petites
structures pour les aider à inventer
quelque chose de différent
voilà le deuxième pas c'est de donner la
force de donner aux autres ce qu'ils
créent ceux qui osent ceux qui innovent
la possibilité de créer il faut les
accompagner
la troisième chose que j'ai apprise
c'est qu'il faut partir de sons à sont
essentielles sont à à soi c'est une
jeune femme à l'agencé qui m'a appris ça
un jour qui le jour j'ai voulu la
recruter après son stage m'a dit c'est
génial je le reste mais plus tard là je
pars un peu déstabilisant dix mois elle
est partie 10 mois avec son amoureux
faire le premier tour du monde du repas
chez l'habitant déjeuner dîner ils sont
allés cuisiner avec les habitants du
monde entier pour voir ce que signifiait
préparer partager un repas
ils sont rentrés un livre very foot trip
top ten en ce moment sur les ventes sur
amazon
marine est revenu à lagence avec elle
nous avons créé une deuxième plateforme
fingers enders
les penseurs et les acteurs qui
s'engagent dans les secteurs de
l'entrepreneuriat de l'éducation des
nouvelles énergies des smart cities ceux
qui inventent un monde différent des
solutions ceux qui essayent en janvier
dernier à l'institut du monde arabe
linkers enders
ce forum a rassemblé 1600 personnes
venus de 22 pays du monde voilà c'est ce
à partir de sons à deux sont essentiels
forcément ce soir j'ai envie de vous
demander quel est votre à votre point de
départ le projet que vous auriez envie
de porter pour faire différemment
peut-être un peu plus positivement en
tout cas essayé j'ai envie de demander
aux institutions aux gouvernements aux
grandes entreprises aux associations
quelles sont leurs à leur évidence leur
envie de créer quelque chose de
différent
c'est avec leurs puissants
organisation leur puissance de diffusion
qu'on pourra encore accéléré les idées
et les innovations qui sont dans notre
petite plate forme parce que c'est bien
ça le sujet de ce soir c'est comment on
donne plus de souffle comment on rend
plus forte cette énergie qui existent un
peu partout nos armes de construction
massive c'est votre cas et notre
puissance créative collective moi aussi
je vous ai laissé un truc dans vos sacs
je vous ai laissé une carte postale
celle qu'on distribuait le soir aux
visiteurs de l'échappée belle ce
parcours anti crise je vous invite dès
ce soir à écrire votre à votre projet
votre point de départ et à la poster à
la personne ou les personnes avec qui
vous auriez envie de réaliser ce projet
je terminerai sur les mots de jacques
brel qui en 1968 disait déjà je vous
souhaite des rêves à n'en plus finir et
l'envi furieuse d'en réaliser quelques
uns
je vous souhaite de résister à
l'indifférence à la mélancolie aux
vertus négatif de notre époque
je vous souhaite surtout d'être vous l'
aventure c'est le trésor qu'on découvre
à chaque matin alors allons-y
massivement il est temps je vous
souhaite dès ce soir le à de l' aventure
avec un très grand à merci